i would say without a shadow of a doubt
it's a tie between New York and Paris
New York has a long history of
collecting 20th century design because
many of the great French designers of
the 1920s and 1930s Ruhlman Frank ratto
had clients here in New York and there's
you know New Yorkers have always been
Franco fill 'ok they do not look to los
angeles to go and acquire work they look
to paris and they always look to Paris
before they look to London when it comes
to acquiring furniture at the same time
Paris isn't just living off of its
reputation Paris has been at the
forefront of the marketing of
contemporary design many of today's
hybrid contemporary architects /
designers whether it's someone like Marc
Newson and maintains a residence in
Paris to the great modular architecture
grew bond maintain residences in Paris
their galleries are there their agents
are there so there are some cutting-edge
collections by such kind of fashion
luminaries in Paris like Azzedine Alaia
who have main maintained Parisian
relevance
you